>> LAST YEAR I MOVED TO IOWA TO
HELP BUILD A GRASSROOTS
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
AS THE CAMPAIGN TOOK OFF, THE
QUESTION CAME UP OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET THE
AGENDA THROUGH CONGRESS?
THIS IS MY ANSWER.
JOIN THE MOVEMENT AND LETS FIX
THE SYSTEM TOGETHER.
>> Jason: THAT WAS JONATHAN
HERZOG, A FORMER TOP STAFFER ON
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE ANDREW YANG'S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, AND NOW
HE'S FORMALLY ANNOUNCED SINCE HE
LEFT THE CAMPAIGN A BIT OF HIS
OWN TO UNSEAT HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN JERRY NADLER
IN NEW YORK'S TENTH
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
JOINING ME NOW FOR A "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE" EXCLUSIVE IS
JONATHAN HERZOG.
I APPRECIATE, RESPECT ANYBODY
WAS WILLING TO THROW THEIR HAT
THE RING OF THINGS THEY CAN DO
SOMETHING BETTER.
ESPECIALLY AGAINST THE LONG-TERM
IN COMMON.
I TOOK ON SOMEBODY IN MY PARTY
HAD BEEN THERE FOR 14 YEARS AND
I BEAT HIM.
IT CAN BE DONE.
EVEN A SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY.
YOUR PLATFORM, I'VE GOT TO TELL
YOU WHEN I LOOK AT IT, FREEDOM
DIVIDEND, MEDICARE FOR ALL.
DEMOCRACY DOLLARS THAT YOU CALL,
IS THAT REALLY WHAT IT TAKES IN
ORDER TO WIN IN NEW YORK'S TENTH
DISTRICT?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
THE REASON I'M RUNNING ON THIS
PLATFORM AS WE ARE GOING THROUGH
A FUNDAMENTAL ECONOMIC SHIFT.
THE GREATEST OF OUR HISTORY
WHERE WE ARE AUTOMATING AWAY THE
MOST COMMON JOBS IN OUR ECONOMY.
WORKING IN RETAIL IS STILL THE
MOST COMMON JOB.
UNTIL WE NEED TO ENACT
MEANINGFUL SOLUTIONS TO HELP
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF FOLKS
HERE IN NEW YORK AND ESPECIALLY
IN THE TENTH DISTRICT TRANSITION
THROUGH THIS FUNDAMENTAL
ECONOMIC SHIFT.
>> Jason: HOW DO YOU BEAT
JERRY NADLER?
HE'S BEEN THERE FOR A LONG TIME.
HE IS A POWERFUL JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN.
HOW DO YOU BEAT AND THEN COMMENT
LIKE THAT IN NEW YORK CITY?
>> STARTS WITH PROPOSING BOTH
SOLUTIONS THAT ADDRESS THE
CENTRAL CHALLENGES OF OUR TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU HAVE A TRILLION
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZON,
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZONL
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZONT
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZONS
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZONY
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZON,
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZONP
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZONY
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZONN
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZONG
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZONZ
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZONR
DOLLAR TECH COMPANY LIKE AMAZONO
AND FEDERAL TAXES, THEN
CERTAINLY WE NEED TO LOOK UP AND
SAY WE NEED TO PASS FREEDOM
DIVIDEND OF A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH TO PUT IT INTO THE HANDS,
PUT ECONOMIC RESOURCES DIRECTLY
INTO THE HANDS OF NEW YORKERS.
SO PUTTING FORTH BOLD SOLUTIONS
THAT ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES OF
OUR TIME IS WHAT WILL BRING US
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
>> Jason: JONATHAN, ARE YOU
FOLLOWING IN AOC'S FOOTSTEPS AND
SAYING AMAZON, DON'T COME TO
NEW YORK.
WE DON'T WANT YOU HERE?
>> WE HAVE TO EMBRACE TECHNOLOGY
AND PROGRESS IN ALL THE GREAT
INNOVATIONS THAT ARE COMING OUR
WAY.
>> Jason: COME ON, JONATHAN.
DO YOU WANT AMAZON TO COME TO
NEW YORK, YES OR NO?
>> LOOK, WE ARE PRO-JOBS.
>> Jason: IT WAS A YES-NO
QUESTION.
>> YES, IT'S GOOD TO HAVE JOB
GROWTH.
>> Jason: SO AOC WAS WRONG?
AOC WAS WRONG?
>> [LAUGHS]
WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE FACT
THAT IF YOU GO TO THE AMAZON
GHOST OR --
>> Jason: NO, NO, NO.
JONATHAN.
I DO THIS FOR A LIVING.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET A LOT OF IT
IF YOU'RE RUNNING, WAS AOC WRONG
OR RIGHT?
>> LOOK.
OUR FOCUS IS ON MAKING SURE THAT
THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF FOLKS
WHO WORK RIGHT NOW IN RETAIL
HAVE A MEANINGFUL PATH FORWARD
AND A TRANSITION.
RIGHT HERE IN THE TENTH
DISTRICT, WE LOST 10,000 RETAIL
JOBS OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS.
SO WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE
PROBLEMS ON THE GROUND FACING
NEW YORKERS.
WE HAVE A MIND-SET OF ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL INSECURITY.
AND WE HAVE TO PUT RESOURCES
INTO OUR HANDS TO HELP US MOVE
FORWARD.
>> Jason: WELL, LISTEN, I
APPRECIATE IT.
YOU WERE HARVARD LAW, YOU'RE
VERY ACCOMPLISHED.
I LOVE YOU HAVE PASSION FOR
BEING INVOLVED IN HELPING OUT ON
THE PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
WE NEED GOOD PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE.
THE ONLY THING I WILL CHALLENGE
YOU WITH AND I WON'T GIVE YOU
ENOUGH TIME TO ANSWER
UNFORTUNATELY, WHILE YOU DID
WELL IN HARVARD LAW MAYBE NOT SO
GOOD IN MATH BECAUSE GIVING
250 MILLION PEOPLE, ADULTS, A
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH ADDS UP
TO TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
I THINK $3 TRILLION.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GET FROM
HERE TO THERE.
I WILL GIVE YOU 20 SECONDS.
>> THE HEADLINE COST IS MUCH
LOWER BUT WE HAVE TO ASK THE
QUESTION AND LOOK UP, HOW IS IT
THAT THESE TRILLION DOLLAR
COMPANIES ARE PAYING ZERO IN
TAXES, LESS THAN YOU AND I?
THIS IS THE KEY CHALLENGE.
>> Jason: THERE'S A REASON FOR
THAT.
WE WILL DO THE TAX THING.